le bruit que vous entendez et celui du
générateur qui alimente cette tente en
chauffage et en électricité un point
d'invincibilité comme l'appel les
Ukrainiens symbole de la résistance
ukrainienne face aux frappe russe des
tentes comme celle-ci il y en a des
milliers à travers tout le pays elles
ont été installées pour faire face aux
coupures de courant mais aussi aux
coupures d'Internet ici les habitants de
rerson viennent charger leur portable
ils profitent également d'Internet et
d'une boisson chaude ils sont là aussi
pour en profiter pour discuter certains
étudiants travaillent une parenthèse
appréciée par ses habitants ils ont
bombardé juste à côté de ma maison et
mes fenêtres ont volé en éclat
maintenant l'hiver arrive j'ai juste
réussi à les recouvrir avec du carton et
du ruban adhésif
est-ce qu'on peut dire que les Russes
sont humains après ce qu'ils ont fait
de quoi veulent-ils nous libérer de la
vie que nous aimions et avions
avantibilité devrait continuer à se
multiplier selon l'un des principaux
opérateurs énergétiques du pays près de
la moitié du réseau électrique
ukrainien est hors d'usage